this is iPhone 10 not x10 not to be
confused with DMX Xbox one X or OS X
which is actually OS 10 await you say
what happened to nine with an all-new
edge-to-edge 5.8 inch OLED super retina
HDR display this is iPhone 10 it's 10
because it's the 10th anniversary of the
first iPhone today Apple is going to
reinvent the phone
ten years ago Steve Jobs introduced the
first iPhone on stage at Macworld 2007
and I was there
spinning around shortly and you'll be
able to see the front of it I saw it in
person inside the spinning glass display
and little did I know at the time that
this phone would change my life not just
mine
everyone's this was the start of
creating simplified apps social
networking and laying the groundwork for
new forms of communicating like iMessage
and FaceTime it but the world and our
friends in the palm of our hand like
usual and typical Apple fashion they may
not have been the first to make a
smartphone but they revolutionized
simplified and made it desirable and
mainstream I can promise you that I will
never be the first person in line for
any sort of a beloved
no way this is it like we're here we're
first this year was special Apple
announced the new iPhone 10 at the Steve
Jobs theater at their new Apple park
campus this was the first event that
they had ever held there and it was a
beautiful reminder of what Steve Jobs
started 10 years ago with the first
original iPhone and it was only fitting
that Steve should open his theater I
remember a time back in my day when you
couldn't even copy and paste on the
first iOS started from the bottom now
we're what is that what happens you got
there that's nice you've got your Wi-Fi
on so what's new with iPhone 10 you
asked
it's got face ID instead of using touch
ID because there's no longer a home
button on the iPhone 10 you use your
face to unlock your phone hopefully you
weren't too attached to that touch ID
because your face is now the replacement
with the full front edge to edge OLED
screen sacrifices had to be made it's
actually quite shocking how fast face ID
works it just works it's hard to explain
it just works setup is super simple you
just roll your face around following the
on-screen directions and there you go
this is all made possible with the new
true depth camera it projects and
analyzes more than 30,000 invisible dots
on your face to create a very very very
precise map your face is now registered
for logging in and face pain yes
face pay just double click the side
button and just as you would with touch
ID Apple pay pops up and I just bought a
cheese will that looks like a pumpkin
with my face
it's so great like I just paid with my
face but what if I'm wearing a hat or
glasses or I get old or get Botox I'm
not quite sure but Apple has promised us
that it will learn your face as you
change whatever that means
privacy is obviously a huge concern for
most people and if it's not then you
should really rethink your priorities
with face ID'd there's a one in a
million chances of a stranger unlocking
your phone randomly whereas with touch
ID it's 1 in 50,000 of course if you
have an identical twin
then those chances are a little bit
higher I don't have a twin and all the
twins that I know were unavailable to
help me with this day I've seen I'd love
to help you but I'm trying to win
Dancing with the Stars right now and
Jonathan he's busy bench-pressing
kitchens here is mine on twin sister she
can't get into my phone using her face
even though people say we look alike but
I don't really see it now what did she
chases me around and tries to use my
face to gain access into my phone even
though I don't want her to this scenario
I'm sure will be replicated if someone
refuses to unlock their phone for you
there is an extra layer of protection to
avoid this from happening by turning on
attention awareness it'll only unlock
your phone when you're looking at it
this will also be used in some apps so
that they'll know that you're actually
looking at your phone and avoid dimming
the screen from inactivity if you're
still not sold on face ID that's okay
you can still opt to use just the good
old fashioned passcode all this talk of
face ID and removal of the home button
justine how do we do things using the
same familiar gestures in iOS will get
you around your new iphone 10 just fine
a simple swipe up and you're back to the
home screen swipe down in the top right
corner for access to your control center
to get to your notifications you can
swipe down on the left or you can swipe
down right here on the top swipe up in
paws to show your current open apps
press and hold on those open apps to
delete you can swipe up or you can press
this little delete button to remove them
you can also access these by swiping
left and right at the very bottom of
your screen you can also use hey Siri if
you have that turned on just by saying
hey Siri that will activate Siri on your
iPhone no stop it I'm recording vo Siri
the on button is now a dedicated Siri
button press and hold to ask Siri a
question I ever tell you that I actually
met the voice of Siri
some of you may already know this but if
you don't this is Susan Bennett the
voice of Siri what's your favorite
staple all my favorite phrases I don't
know and I don't care to turn off your
iPhone 10 you hold the power button and
the volume button down you can also turn
it off in the software in iOS 11 which I
actually had no idea about until finding
it right now so take a screenshot you
hold the power and the volume up button
magically with these screenshots the
notch does not appear what kind of
sorcery is this one of the things that
I've been looking forward to forever is
wireless charging both the iPhone 10 and
the iPhone 8 are embedded with Qi
wireless charging and it has an all-new
glass back this is by far the strongest
glass that Apple has ever implemented in
their phones both on the front display
and the back I definitely don't want to
repeat of this this might have been my
first iPhone shatter I think I'm not
sure I've lost track with the air power
out in 2018 you'll finally be able to
charge all of your devices on this this
is a wireless power mat you can charge
all of your devices at the same time and
I mean it's wireless but like it's not
just no wires connected to your devices
you get the point
this here is the fan-favorite top notch
this thing has so much technology packed
into it an infrared camera a flood
illuminator proximity sensor ambient
light sensor speakers microphones front
camera and a dot projector all of this
for animated emojis face ID and portrait
mode selfies but let's be real selfies
are a thing of the past
animated emojis that mirror your exact
expressions of why you're really
dropping on the new iPhone 10 you can
record up to 10 second an emoji videos
and text them to your friends hey Jenna
another thing that I really like about
the in emojis is if you don't want to
send a video you can actually turn it
into a sticker so all I have to do is
instead of hitting record I just make an
emotion and click it can I drag and drop
just like you would do an iMessage
sticker much like the portrait mode that
you may be familiar with you can now use
the front facing camera with new
portrait lighting modes natural light
studio light contour light stage light
and stage light mono I'm not really sure
if this is considered hashtag no filter
but come on we all know those hashtag no
filter photos have been retouched and
edited color corrected face tune face
blurred beyond recognition but hey I did
not a filter right one of the biggest
physical changes and main identifiers to
say hey guys guess what I have the new
iPhone 10 is the rear dual cameras
they've now been rotated vertically with
a quad tone LED flash right in the
center so that everyone will know that
you have the newest iPhone you can also
let them know when they ask about your
new phone that it has a larger and
faster 12 megapixel sensor with improved
optical image stabilization and new on
the iPhone 10 optical image
stabilization on both lenses a new
iPhone 10 features the brand new a 11
Bionic chip that is currently the most
powerful and smartest chip in a
smartphone with the for efficiency cores
and the new CPU it'll be about 70
percent faster than the previous 810
fusion and the two performance scores
are up to 25% faster did I lose you it's
okay
make yourself some flashcards so you'll
have these details ready for a salty
Android user and I'm not hating
I've had plenty of Android phones in my
days I just want you to have the facts
ready one of the things that I just
couldn't get over is how beautiful the
new screen is it has a million to 1
contrast ratio with the best color
accuracy of any previous iPhone they've
also increased the speakers by 35% and
they're in stereo this will make binge
watching an entire Netflix series a
little bit more enjoyable I don't
usually have the true tone display
turned on but depending upon your
current lighting situation your displays
colors will shift to give you the most
accurate representation of what you're
looking at it's pretty easy to switch on
and off so if you find yourself looking
at your screen and wondering why it's
turning a little bit too yellow or a
little bit too blue that could be the
issue another of the things that I'm
loving so much about this new phone
is the video options now with the iPhone
8 and the iPhone 10 you can shoot 4k 60
frames a second and up to 240 frames a
second at 1080p so what that means for
most people is that you're probably
going to eat up a ton of storage really
really really quick but what that means
for making cool high quality videos you
can do that right from your iPhone and
if you're new to my channel welcome I'm
a sucker for slo-mo with the new optical
image stabilization you'll see a
noticeable difference in low-light
photos new and iOS 11 you can loop
bounce and create long exposure shots
from your live photos also with the back
vertical cameras this placement is so
much better aligned for depth sensing
which means increase spatial awareness
for augmented reality I haven't got a
chance to spend much time with any AR
apps but the few that I have a tried are
a lot of fun with all of these new
integrations in the latest iPhone 10 and
the iPhone 8 I'm really looking forward
to seeing what developers are working on
with AR kit so that's the new iPhone 10
it comes in space gray and silver with
storage options of why even bother 64
gigs and oh my gosh I shoot a lot of
holes hey video in photos of white dog
256 gigs leave me some comments below
and let me know what your favorite
iPhone can feature is thank you guys so
much for watching I will see you in my
next video
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this video I had so
much fun making it for you if you liked
it make sure you hit like and don't
forget to subscribe
wink can an emojis wink
[Music]